all right we are going to take a tour
today it's not going to be
a fun tour i i'm not going to lie this
is not exactly touring unesco world
heritage sites and
amazing architecture and sites and views
and these different things landscapes
this is going to be
a tour
through madness quite frankly
the world is increasingly horrified by
the anti-vaccine madness happening
across the united states in media
at school board meetings at rallies and
at other places now many of you would
rightly point out
there have been anti-vaxx elements
in many countries around the world and
you would be right
but the combination of the united states
being one of the countries that first
had access to as many vaccines as we
could possibly want
and being one of the largest and most
powerful countries in the world
combined with the degree of wide-ranging
anti-vaccine insanity
is uh getting a lot of negative
attention for us it's humiliating it's
embarrassing that this is what the
united states is being known for so
let's start the tour first
there was an
anti-vaccine mandate
uh march
in new york city
and this we're just these are anecdotes
we're just dropping in here's one guy
who says that the mandates are orwellian
and like nazi germany which is remember
we did our story last week
anti-vaxxerism and coveted conspiracies
push people towards anti-semitism one
element of that
is the trivialization of the holocaust
because
vaccine requirements that you can test
out of
or like if you want to work here you
should go and get a vaccine otherwise
you're gonna have to test or leave
that's not what the nazis were doing to
the jews okay very very different to to
to to
to say we do not comply to what's going
on with these mandates you know uh this
stuff is orwellian it's uh it's it's
totally uh nazi germany type stuff and
so uh you know we're just done with it
right it is not
orwellian and it is not nazi germany
type stuff um it's just it's just not uh
this same guy was again we don't know
who this guy is just just iran it
doesn't matter is the point it this is a
guy random anti-vaccine activist who's
been infected with this stuff um of
course connected all of it to the
democratic party and said this is all
about what the dems want make you weak
make you dependent destroy the country
this is a widespread narrative among the
right take a look the democrat platform
is founded on this garbage it's founded
on destruction is founded on on making
us weak making us dependent making us uh
uh you know
just
destroying our country right
so the destruction of the country
narrative
make you weak make you dependent on the
government
likening to nazi germany which is a
trivialization of the holocaust it's
checking all the boxes and most of the
world and more than half of the united
states sees this and says
do these people not realize how
humiliating and embarrassing this is
this this is absolutely wild
then just going to something totally
different
here's naomi wolfe naomi wolf is
off the deep end i don't know how many
of you are familiar with naomi wolfe
when i was in college there would be
many classes where we would see clips of
neocommunications courses we would see
clips of naomi wolfe making interesting
critiques and analyses she seems
completely off the deep end and she says
the only people ever subjected to
mandatory vaccinations were slaves what
naomi yeah that's what she says coercing
people to have a vaccination we've never
had that in the united states in our
entire history unless you were an
enslaved person now that's not true
i have no idea where naomi wolf gets
that idea
but
uh
right now
all 50 states plus dc mandate
immunization for a number of conditions
to go to public schools uh diphtheria
tetanus pertussis polio measles you know
there's a long history of vaccine
requirements um
i just some of these things are so
stupid
that you don't even really know what
they mean because it's so obviously
untrue
but now naomi wolf is being held up as
some kind of oracle by some on the right
people who by the way
would never listen to naomi wolfe ever
ever ever uh before
very very strange
then we go to a california high school
teacher this is now going to the school
board part so we've done rally anti-vaxx
back uh rally
we then did um right-wing media that was
like the war room or you know one of
those real america's voice the thing
steve bannon's on and we heard from
naomi wolf now we're going to school
board here's a california high school
teacher who says he will fight the
mandate no matter what it ha what
happens he might lose his job because he
answers to god and his wife now his wife
maybe anti-vaxx i have no reason to
believe that if god exists god is
anti-vaxx i'm still not really aware of
any religion that's just flat out no
vaccines let's take a listen to this guy
i'm willing to fight this mandate for my
family and my community if it means i
lose my job i'll be able to sleep at
night knowing i stood up for freedom and
i'm certain that history will say that
i'm on the right side of science as well
i only answer to god
my wife
not the government
and look at the cheering and the fist
pumping and the usa chant
it's actually hard to think of anything
more anti-american than what that guy is
doing i mean truly truly uh now we will
go from a school board meeting remember
it's a tour through the insanity we're
now going to the floor of the house of
representatives here is congressman long
with some very strange comparison
between the military requiring vaccines
and i think he's talking about new coke
take a listen see if you can figure it
out 1886 a product was brought online
coca-cola and it remained one of the
most popular products of all time until
1985 99 years later and they came out
with a great idea new coke right problem
is new coke was a terrible
that's the problem
idea
and three months later they brought back
what they call classic coke because of
this terrible terrible idea that had to
be fixed making our military be
vaccinated against their will is a
terrible terrible idea that needs to be
fixed now the funny thing is it's not a
new idea there have been vaccination
requirements in the military
for a really i don't even know how long
for a really long time they're just
adding the covet 19 vaccine as happens
when new vaccines are developed they get
added as requirements for the military
the really funny thing is it's nothing
like new coke actually
i don't want to go on a whole tangent
in business school
we did a case study on new coke new coke
is a really interesting business case
study actually uh there was also another
one i think like pepsi clear it tasted
like pepsi but it looked it was
transparent and i think that also failed
um in any case very interesting business
discussion about new the history of new
coke the analogy to a vaccine
requirement for the military simply not
there um then oh this is really
interesting so then on fox news
they talk about a clip of cdc director
rochelle walensky
saying we need to educate people about
the vaccine so they become comfortable
going and getting it they need to learn
about the vaccine and fox news acts as
if what she's talking is about
re-education
alluding to re-education camps and
dictatorships but rachelle wolenski
didn't say it take a look at this
mayor de blasio has warned city workers
if they don't get the vaccine by friday
they will be put on unpaid leave and now
the cdc is planning to quote educate
those who are hesitant to get the shot
here's cdc director rochelle
we believe it is very important to get
these people vaccinated there is a plan
should these people not want to be
vaccinated towards education and
counseling to get people the information
they need so that they are feeling
comfortable in getting vaccinated
something about the phrase re-education
she didn't say re-education you notice
what they did there she didn't say
re-education she just said we've got to
educate people about the science of the
vaccine and get these people on board
seems uh pretty strikingly similar to a
really tragic chapter in our globe's
history i get i don't know what i don't
know if she's talking about
uh
slavery or the holocaust it's not even
clear what she's referring to but it's
crazy and then they build on this they
just continue building building building
on it even though it was it rachelle
willenski said we've got to educate
and the host says re-education whoa and
they just keep going harris part of what
is so troubling is the notion of that
again the reprogramming and education
where she never said reprogramming that
i mean
there they they came up with that out of
thin air you are automatically branded
an enemy you are automatically branded
frankly a criminal in some sectors if
you dare to even question if you dare to
to expect what we were promised so you
get it they they introduced the term
re-education which rachelle walensky
didn't
and uh here is tommy tomy lauren saying
she's so proud of people standing up
against this i'd also like to say this
when we see this protest in brooklyn and
we see these workers standing up when i
saw those images nothing made me feel
more proud to be an american because i
saw americans of every color every shape
every size every gender and probably
every political affiliation standing
together in the name of freedom that's
american as it gets yeah so you guys get
the idea an absolute humiliation
globally for the united states it's
everywhere it's on right-wing media it's
on the floor of the house it's at
rallies
it's everywhere and um i don't think
it's going away anytime soon let's now
talk about something
opposite this when it comes to vaccines
one of our sponsors is privacy.com
they're giving you five dollars when you
sign up for their completely free
service at privacy.com pacman i've been
using privacy for a little over a year
now you've heard me talk about it before
it's a lifesaver and here's how it works
takes just a couple of minutes to set up
anytime you buy something online or on
the phone
instead of actually using your real
credit card number the privacy app and
the browser plugin
let you give each company a randomized
virtual credit card number that you
create out of thin air it'll even
autofill the card number with one click
and the payment is taken out of your
checking account without the merchant
ever knowing your real information so
this allows you to keep your banking
information secure but also to take
control of your finances you can create
up to 12 of these virtual credit cards a
month you can set spending limits you
can freeze them you can delete them
anytime you want so when you do this it
means you're not going to be charged
when you don't want to be because you
can destroy the virtual card number
right after using it which for instance
i love using free trials because i know
i won't be charged when the trial is
over if i use a virtual credit card
number you're keeping your identity
private
by not telling companies who you are
you're keeping your bank or credit card
info protected against data breaches and
identity theft and it's free there's no
catch whatsoever but if you want privacy
also offers a ten dollar a month plan
that gives you one percent cash back and
lets you create 36 credit cards a month
and a 25 a month plan tailored more for
small businesses where you can create 60
card numbers a month and much more but
definitely go ahead and at least get
started with the free plan you'll
protect your financial info companies
can't charge you unexpectedly and like i
said you'll get five dollars to spend
when you sign up at privacy.com slash
pacman